pau
[Musique]
un nouveau gouvernement nouveau ministre
de l'outre-mer et comme le veut l'usagé
le nouvel hôte de l'hôtel de montmorin
reçoit les parlementaires et présidents
d'exécutifs ultramarins pour ce premier
discours de rencontre annick girardin a
plaidé sa volonté de travailler en bonne
intelligence avec les représentants des
outre-mer réservés l'accompagnement de
l'état veut annick girardin réaffirmé la
volonté du gouvernement de tenir de
nouvelles assises pour l'outre-mer des
assises dont la présidente du conseil
départemental ne vois pas bien l'intérêt
je n'approuve pas et je ne crois pas aux
assises a organisé qui vont encore nous
prendre du temps un an alors qu'il ya
aujourd'hui les vraies solutions à
apporter
la réunion traverse par exemple une
crise avec la filière canne comment
apporter à la jeunesse des solutions sur
l'emploi sur la formation comment faire
en sorte que nous puissions coopérer
avec tous les pays de la zone océan
indien mais en nous donnant des accords
dès aujourd'hui c'est à dire rapidement
et non et non pas revoir des assises je
crois qu'il ya aujourd'hui beaucoup de
deux fiches de travail qui ont déjà été
élaborés
rentrons dans du pratico-pratique ses
ouailles ce que je revendique des
solutions vite et durable ce rendez-vous
est surtout l'occasion pour nassimah
dindar comme pour les élus réunionnais
présents de faire entendre sa voix dans
ce lieu de pouvoir ou de nombreuses
décisions concernant l'île sont prises
pour le député maire de saint leu il
s'agit d'un nouveau départ qui fait
suite à l'élection d' emmanuel macron je
crois que au delà d'une tradition
il ya de l'espoir qu'a suscitée
l'élection d' emmanuel macron à la
présence de la république et aujourd'hui
il faut transformer cet espoir qui a été
créé et installé dans la tête de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
ultramarins en des éléments concrets
cette première rencontre permet bien sûr
de nouer de nouveaux contacts
si de nombreuses têtes sont ici déjà
connu d'autres son nouvel arrivé très
tôt nassimah dindar a pu ainsi
rencontrer tous les élus locaux
mais c'est avant tout auprès de la
nouvelle ministre que les ambitions
réunionnaise de repasser il faut savoir
se faire entendre
d'abord c'est une invitation de la
ministre de l'outre-mer dans un cadre
bien défini
c'est ce que nous présenter le
calendrier des assises de votre mère
tous les parlementaires soient les
sénateurs ou que ce soit les visites et
doivent évidemment être présents pour
écouter le premier discours officiel
on s'est mises d'accord pour que avoir
une réunion technique sur le territoire
à la réunion pour que les forces vives
puissent être consultés et que on ne
rate pas le coche parce que si on rate
certaines modifications du code du
travail qui demain vont porter atteinte
aux salariés aux entreprises aux tpe/pme
la réunion on va se réveiller trop tard
l'été s'annonce déjà bien chargé chaque
représentant politique locale devra
poursuivre si son travail à paris et la
rentrée sera encore plus active
[Musique]